I'm reading this book now about,
um, speaking of changing your brain,
it's called a how to change your mind.
God is Michael Pollan.
Yeah. He's been on the podcast
talking about, oh, no shit.
Did he talk about his new book, about
the, um, it, it's, it's basically about,
uh,
um,
psychedelics and LSD and mushrooms in
particular and tell it traces the whole
fucking history of it.
I had no idea how much research was done
back in the fifties and sixties. I mean,
they had conclusive studies
that were showing with, um,
alcoholism.
People were 70% of people that underwent
these treatments with psychedelics got
sober. Oh, depression,
cigarettes, cigarettes.
I mean, it's amazing. And all that
shit just got fucking thrown away.
Corrupt people kept that
information away from folks.
The studies that Nixon funded,
like Nixon funded a bunch of studies that
showed positive benefits of marijuana.
How is that right? You know, the
Nixon administration, just fucking,
can I get out of here with this
shit not releasing this one.
The other thing he mentioned
is that it got squashed by,
by shrinks because they had
a vested interest in people
not going into the woods
for a weekend and coming back without
their depression. So yeah, so they,
so they disqualified all
the studies. Oh fuck. Yeah.
What psychiatrists were like horrified
that there was these kind of results were
coming back.
Was it that for sure?
Or was it people who've never taken
psychedelics horrified that people are out
there experimenting with
their consciousness?
Because I think a lot of
these psychiatrists are
probably really straight laced
guys.
And so in their mind,
especially in the shadows
of reefer madness and all
the propaganda they'd heard
in the 30s and forties and when you look
at those people and they're out there
in the fucking desert or wherever
they're going dancing around and taking
mushrooms under the moonlight, you like,
they're blowing their brains out here.
You got to stop this.
If they're straight laced people
that have ever done psychedelics,
they might not be in cahoots.
It might more likely be a bunch of
people that think it's a fucking terrible
idea to let people run
around and take an acid.
Well there was just some of the
medical journals came out with,
with pieces saying that none of these
studies are valid because there wasn't a,
I forget what it is about studies
that have to be consistent. Um,
but the other thing is it was political
and you had Timothy leary who is,
you know,
the worst thing to happen to this kind
of testing because he was saying was it
drop, drop out in turn on, drop,
drop out. And that whole idea,
they said, you know, we're people taking
LSD are not going to fight your wars.
And so that became a threat to the
status quo and that's when the law has
started to come out. Huh. It's interesting
cause he also got a lot of
people to get excited about it,
right? Yeah. But he got,
he took it away from it
being a, um, a medical
process and he made it about,
you know, enlightenment, but
in a kind of fluffy spirit,
joy away. Well, he made
it a big movement. Right.
I think you saw that he was probably
going to change the world with that
movement. Yeah, we kinda did. It
definitely had a big impact. You know,
all those people that took acid.
It's like,
think about if you really stop and think
about apple and you really look at the
fact that apple,
Steve Jobs said that taken acid was like
one of the greatest things that ever
happened to him. Yeah. That was his,
it was famously talked about it.
And who knows what a,
what an impact that had on him deciding
to start apple and what would an impact
apple has had in the technology world.
Oh No.
Paul and talks about it in the book.
He draws a straight line from people
starting to take all this stuff because it
was happening in Silicon Valley.
This whole psychedelic movement was like
right in that area. And he says that it,
you know, Bill, Bill Gates
apparently took it once,
but that all those guys were coming
in and they were, you know, they,
there were these people that would lead.
There was a guy named,
um,
no Hubbard,
well Ron doss has mentioned also,
but there was guy named Hubbard
who was really like, you know,
a corporate version of LSD.
He was going to companies and he was
taking the CEOs of companies and taking
them in for these three
day drop acid experiences.
Wow.
Corporate acid. Well, they're
kind of doing that at burning
man. Oh, is that right?
Some corporations go
to, I mean, not a lot,
but there's some cool companies who
go to burning man. Yeah. You know,
what's this Alfred?
Matthew Hubbard,
he's an early proponent of the drug LSD.
During the 1950s,
he is reputed to be the Johnny
Appleseed of Lsd and the first person to
emphasize led lsds potential as a
visionary or trends in dental truck.
Okay.
But this guy had an a fucking life.
Somebody's got to do a
movie about his life. He,
he was like working for the government.
He was a double agent. He was, uh,
while he was dropping acid. He was,
he, he started with nothing. No, I
think before, before, during and after.
He had like eight different careers
and he was like a spy and he bought it.
He started with nothing and ended up with
like a bunch of airplanes that he was
leasing out,
became a millionaire and then spent it
all trying to educate people on Lsd.
He was worth like tens of millions of
dollars and he ended up broke at the end.
Wow. Yeah. Wow.
All for the LSD,
he believed in it so strongly that said
it was going to change the world and it
would have, it may still now
there's, now it's coming back.
Well, there was a little hiccup or several
generations how to pass before people
started understanding that there's there,
there's a risk to everything.
There's a risk to a sports.
There's a risk to every fucking thing
you do driving your cars are at risk.
There's a risk with psychedelics,
but there's also a reward and I
think if you're going to be honest,
do you have to look at both of them?
You have to look at the potential risk.
You have to look at the reward and they're
not looking at the reward to try this.
Too many people out there that are trying
to deny the reward and you've got to
find out why. And in this day
and age it might be a conspiracy,
it might be some pharmaceutical industry
that doesn't want it to be legal
because it would undermine their profits.
It might be,
it might be some law enforcement unions
that think it's a bad idea to make less
things illegal. It will take,
you know, prisons. Yeah.
It will take people away,
you know,
in terms of the amount of people that
they need for the job. It'll, you know,
which I think that's
another story. But when you,
you know,
and people look at that kind of
stuff and you look at like the,
the underlying sort of patterns
that we follow in this country,
you know,
the patterns that we like,
are you happy or not happy
with the way things go?
The way things are run.
Okay.
In what sense? Just in
any sense. In all of it.
Yeah.
I trust that we do have the best system
out there and we challenge it every day.
And I still think that we live in a place
where the tenants of our society are
in place for sure they
swing one way or the other,
but I still believe in democracy.
And um,
I think the internet as an as an overall
thing has been positive for people
getting their voices out and for,
for information period
being distributed.
But the I,
the idea that we're faced
with that in this day and age,
there's grown adults telling other grown
adults what they can and can't put in
their body. Yeah. And then not being
honest about the benefits. Right.
That's where it gets squirrely.
That's where the whole thing falls apart.
Like you're just a guy.
Like if you and I are the only two people
on the planet and he only came out,
I'm not going to let you take
that acid. Like why? Well,
because it's illegal. Look, I wrote it
down. Can, can't take the acid. Right.
Well that would be preposterous.
Yeah. But somehow or another,
it works when there's a million people
that a person could tell you, you know,
if you're a fucking grown adult,
you can't tell me what I can take.
That's stupid. Yeah. If,
if you can't prove beyond a shadow of
a doubt that what I'm going to take is
gonna fuck with you. If you can't
prove that, then stop. Yeah. Look,
if someone does something,
if takes something and does somebody
take PCP and they've run phase first
through a fucking seven 11 window
that's on them, it's on their actions.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't be able
to try PCP and I don't think you should
try PCP. I think when enough enough people
smashed through windows and go crazy,
you go, hey, maybe that's a
drug I should fucking avoid.
But that's how you find out about that.
Yeah.
You let grown adults make own decisions
and if you're the one who's making the
decisions for all the grown adults,
you better have some real fucking
logic to what you're saying it.
And this is the same society that allows
the pharmaceuticals to peddle opiates
to people for the last 30 years saying
that it was the greatest thing you could
do.
Exactly.
I think it's good that they make money
because they make medicine that helps a
lot of people. They're not
all bad. I think in general,
pharmaceuticals have helped
people in tremendous ways,
but you can't deny that
if there's some way,
shape or form that people are
influencing other people having access to
beneficial things because it would
impact their profit line. That's,
that's evil. That's evil. You
have a lot of fucking money.
If you really going out of your way
to hire lobbyists to make sure that
mushrooms don't get on
the table, come on, man.
You're you are. You're a fucking
real problem. That's a real problem.
If you look at Yin and Yang,
this is,
this is the opposing forces that were
battling to try to get total complete
freedom of your consciousness. These are
the opposing forces, their ignorance,
like these psychiatrists,
I guarantee you these psychiatrists
were worried about correlations between
psychotic episodes and psychedelic drug
use and they're worried about people
falling apart and they're right.
They're right.
This are the ones that wanted
to get it illegal debt, right.
It's like working on backflips
when there's a fucking
thin pad under you. Yeah.
You could fall on your head. Yeah, you're
right. And we say, don't do gymnastics.
People fall in their head.
One out of 10 falls on their head.
You're not doing chimney, not
falling on your fucking head. Right.
It's the same thing.
So people worried about it that
don't really have experience in it.
I guarantee you most of
those psychiatrists just
didn't have experience in it.
Or we're super cautious folks is if
they did have experiences with it,
maybe they try a little mushroom
dose and they'd be like,
wow, this is amazing. His
brain and also controlling,
um, you know, uh, s set and
setting, they keep talking about,
you know, and realizing
that the, the, you know,
occurrence of a psychotic episode is
so much lower when it's, you know,
when you're, when it's being
dispensed the right way so much lower.
You ever been led through it by somebody.
Now when you did IOWASCA
was there like a guy, EMT,
Aubrey, my friend Aubrey acted as
a sign of like set the setting.
I'm in a way where it was, uh, you know,
I would say like spiritual,
like not
dot Riddick.
Not over the top,
but just announcing your intentions
that we're going into this,
we're going in this,
we're going to let go,
we're going to give thanks.
The all, all the spirits around
us and all the energy around us.
Just go into this with a good
intention. Give, be grateful.
Be uh,
go into it with gratitude.
And then the way it hits you,
it hits you like,
like a
infinite cyclone of geometric
patterns in impossible colors.
Just blasting in your brain
instantaneously and you like,
like going into it with the intention of
letting go is probably one of the best
pieces of advice you could give
people to uh, avoid a freakout, right?
Go with it, let it go.
Just let yourself go.
And it's what's trying to do is your ego
is trying to wrestle with this grizzly
bear. This enormous short face
bear on steroids is trying to,
your ego's trying to wrestle with
is impossible to resist force.
And that's what leads to a lot
of people freaking out. So Iga,
losing your ego is the
ultimate goal of it. Um,
I don't think anybody ever really
loses her ego. I think you,
you keep it in check.
You lose some of it.
You keep some of it because that's part
of your survival mechanism that the real
problem is like having a
healthy ego. You know, like, uh,
like if your wife looks good and she's
looking at herself in the mirror and she
was like, I look good. You
look fucking great. I do look
good. Like she feels good.
It feels everybody. That's ego, right?
You want to know you, you look good,
but it's not a bad ego. It's fun.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah.
The real problem is when it gets out of
control and toxic than it looked like
other people see it. They're like,
if you, you know, you see gross,
just gross behavior, grow
selfishness, you see that you'll go,
oh, that's the bad part of the
ego. That's what I'm saying. Yeah.
But the key is to know which is which,
and that's hard.
It's hard to know which is which.
Which one is the overwhelming
force inside your mind?
Which one is the one that's controlling
your consciousness and your behavior in
which is, is it the good one, the bad one?
Is it the fun healthy one or is
it the one that is a, you know,
completely obsessed with
yourself and only yourself?
You don't know until you have these
experiences. And then the, the,
the nature of them gets exposed.
It like takes him down to the roots
and you start thinking about a,
where did all this come from?
Like where is it? Where's all,
what's the source of all this? Like,
oh, there's a validation issue.
There's a this issue, there's a
trust issue, there's a, you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's swirling out of that in this
unnatural form to create the negative
behavior that you are or
manifesting in your life like it.
All of it comes from something.
And one of the things about
psychedelic experiences is it shut it,
like it shuts the ego off for a second
and lets you stand outside of it and go
look with the things Dunia look at
this thing, things, grubs, and yeah,
it doesn't work.